good morning John I have done the
science and the results the results are
shocking I got to sign a lot of pieces
of paper for the sign edition of my new
book a beautifully foolish endeavor out
July 7th you can order them now there's
links in the description so I figured
this is like a once in a lifetime
opportunity for some science so I went
on the Amazon and I spent an
irresponsibly large amount of money
buying permanent markers biggest problem
is that many times to get one black
marker I would have to buy the entire
rainbow but I did it John and you want
to know I actually really enjoyed this
entire process now there's a few caveats
here one I'm going to spend way more
than four minutes on this video so it'll
be a long version over on a Hank's
chance second this is not a
comprehensive collection of all the
permanent markers in the world it's only
the ones that I could find easily and
third this isn't really a scientific I
only tested one of each kind of marker
for example when I stopped was
subjective it was when I felt like the
marker wasn't doing well enough anymore
this is the Ticonderoga ready sharp plus
this is my favorite feeling pen burst
it's got this little thumb divot that
lets you push the cap off really easily
and it's also one of the few pens here
that has a soft rubber grip and the
third thing that makes this pen a more
pleasant experience is the smell
it'll has almost none this pen uses a
completely different chemistry than all
the other pens here and it makes it less
damaging to plastics chemistry
apparently can also hold less ink it's
signed about a third of what our leading
champions here jazz for the worst
experiences the second worse I'm going
to say is the u.s. art supply only
because the cap doesn't fit well on the
base and that Wiggles around and falls
off and if I can't be held responsible
for where my pen cap is that's
definitely the worst experience is the
pocket shark which is a pen that has a
screw on cap and is designed to
withstand like war which is ridiculous
because it only signed like 75 sheets of
paper so I don't need the outside of the
pen to last a long time when the inside
isn't going to last at all but the
biggest problem with it is that it is
just extremely unpleasant to sign with
now two of our top contenders for
longevity of marker are very thin
markers because of course when you have
a thinner point less ink comes out per
signature what a Sharpie does and why
they call it a Sharpie is it's actually
sure
at the tip and so when you first start
signing with a sharpie you having less
ink come out per signature as time goes
on the Sharpie actually gets more dull
and more ink comes up for signature at
the same time there's less ink in the
pen and over time especially when the
pen is moving fast the ink isn't being
laid down fast enough and so you get
these gaps in the signature now people
who talk about whether Sharpie is the
best sharpie it really have one major
contender in mind and that is the
Milwaukee inks all it is a thinner tip
than the sharpie because it has that
thinner tip it's going to have more
longevity per amount of ink inside it
and I like this pen and went really
smooth that lasted a long time I like
the design of it but it was not not not
our longevity when John and you've said
this to me you said you've tried every
permanent marker there is and that
Sharpie makes the best marker and John I
am willing to say that some pen
companies do better on the ergonomics a
sharpie nonetheless and not by a huge
margin did have the most longevity of
any pen I tried every time I went back
to the Sharpie after using some of these
other pens it was just better but John
there is also a stack of paper here that
I did not include has a final twist at
the end and it is a massive stack it is
50% higher than the traditional sharpie
what pen is that might you ask John it
is the metal sharpie the tip is less
sharp but it laid down some egg takes
out the sharpest tool in the shed but it
definitely has the most longevity I
really thought this would be like super
worth doing that I might find some
diamond somewhere but Sharpie really
does have it figured out and this what
am I supposed to do with this John I'll
see you on Tuesday